je vous rassure et
le gouvernement qui m'a été donné de
voir mercredi comprend très bien ce que
président la république dit et plus
sérieusement sur le premier sujet que
vous avez évoqué je lis redit lors des
voeux
la être citoyen c'est avoir des droits
et des devoirs et ce sont d'abord des
devoirs et j'avais eu l'occasion de le
dire à plusieurs reprises aussi le
concept de liberté qui est brandi
aujourd'hui par certains de nos
compatriotes pour diriger la liberté de
ne pas me faire vacciner il s'arrête là
où la liberté de l'autre est à ce
moment-là entravé là où la vie de
l'autre peut être mise en danger il faut
bien voir que ce ne sont pas des
déclarations que j'ai faites c'est dans
leur entretien de deux heures avec lui
de nos compatriotes que l'un de vos
confrères avait sélectionné
la totalité des gens avec qui je parlais
été
un vivier à l'égard de nos compatriotes
qui ne veulent pas se faire vacciner
j'avais face à moi deux soignantes qui
me disaient mais nous on pense qu'il ne
faut plus soigner les gens qui ne sont
pas vaccinés quand ils arrivent aux
urgences de là où je suis je ne peux pas
ne pas être préoccupé par cela je voyais
des tribunes de médecins des zones où il
veut plus soigner les gens qui arrivent
aux urgences qui ne sont pas vaccinés et
donc on peut s'émouvoir sur des formes
d'expression qui paraissent familière
que j'assume totalement moi je m'émeus
de la situation dans laquelle nous
sommes la vraie fracture du pays hélas
quand certains font de leur liberté qui
devient une responsabilité un slogan non
seulement ils mettent en danger de la
vie d autres mais ils restreignent la
liberté des autres
il s'agit je ne peux pas l'accepter et
je ne peux pas laisser prospérer dans
notre pays des débats qui consisterait à
dire ne les soigne on pas par ses choix
non je les dis aussi très clairement
donc ce que je dis c'est qu'être citoyen
c'est aussi accepter les devoirs qui
vont avec cette citoyenneté et donc
quand on est citoyen on doit accepter de
remplir son devoir
ensuite oui j'assume totalement et c'est
ce que nous faisons au fond depuis l'été
dernier
on a une stratégie qui est simple
vacciner vacciner vaccinée elle est
européenne et gelé rappelait encore à
plusieurs reprises heureusement que nous
avons l'europe pour dès le début avoir
obtenu ces doses puis être le premier
continent de production une production
ouverte pour le monde entier parce que
nous avons plus exporté est donnée de
doses que nous n'en avons gardé pour
nous mêmes donc la vaccination c'est
notre priorité
ensuite le deuxième pilier c'est le pass
pass sanitaire devenant passe vaccinale
pourquoi parce que c'est un mécanisme
qui permet de protéger les uns et les
autres quand on est dans un espace
commun et c'est aussi une stratégie qui
a été adoptée partout en europe avec des
modalités techniques différentes mais
qui est de protéger les autres et de se
dire quand on va au restaurant quand on
va au spectacle
quand on est dans une même salle et bien
on sait mon statut
et on avance mais je dois d'ailleurs
dire que le pass vaccinale est inspiré
de l'initiative qui avait été prise
avant nous par le luxembourg l'allemagne
autres nous nous avions un passani terre
comme vous le savez qui permettait
d'être vaccinés ou tester dans les lieux
de convivialité
plusieurs de nos voisins avait mis ce
qu'ils appellent 2g ou 2 et plus avant
que nous en venions à ses décisions il
fallait ou être guéries ou à revoir son
schéma vaccinal complet donc c'est un
mouvement complètement européen et qui
fait quoi qui met des restrictions sur
les personnes qui ne sont pas vaccinés
et donc ce mouvement vous le voyez
partout en europe alors certains font
l'obligation vaccinale au dessus d'un
certain âge mais la plupart des pays
mettent des contraintes de la vie
sociale en disant si vous n'êtes pas
vacciné vous n'avez pas accès à ce lieu
vous n'avez pas accès à cette activité
et nous sommes obligés de le faire pour
inciter
pousser les uns et les autres elle fait
et je le dis avec
beaucoup de volonté et de force nous
devons faire cela nous devons le faire
pour l'ensemble de nos compatriotes qui
font l'effort de se faire vacciner et
qui par l'irresponsabilité de certains
autres parfois les choix assumé sont
contaminés et nous devons le faire aussi
pour nos compatriotes qui parfois se
laisse prendre par des discours
obscurantiste par des discours de peur
et ne se protègent pas eux mêmes alors
que la science la recherche et
l'excellence technologique et productive
européenne leur permet voilà donc il
était je crois de ma responsabilité de
tirer de sonner un peu la larme c'est ce
que j'ai fait cette semaine pour voilà
que les choses puissent avancer encore
plus rapidement